KORY JEFFREY:
Welcome, everybody.
We are on site in San Francisco
at the Founder World event.
Joining me in studio
today is Tony Capasso,
founder of Construction
Automation.
Tony, how are you?
TONY CAPASSO: I'm good.
How are you doing?
KORY JEFFREY: Thanks
for joining me.
TONY CAPASSO: Yeah.
Thank you for having me.
KORY JEFFREY: So tell me
about Construction Automation.
TONY CAPASSO: Sure.
So my background is construction
and real estate development.
And I've seen this common
theme of there being
a shortage of skilled workers.
Obviously, as we all
know, real estate
is super expensive and
almost unaffordable.
So I aim to solve
those problems, which
I think are massive global
issues with construction.
And I think the
future of construction
is going to heavily
involve robotics.
So I did a bunch of research
into thinking how I can totally
transform the industry
by kind of combining
3D printing, robotics into
the building industry.
So there's a huge opportunity,
but that's my aim to solve.
KORY JEFFREY:
Sounds really cool.
So is it 3D printing of
particular materials?
Or is it a different
way to 3D print?
TONY CAPASSO: Sure.
So initially, it's going to
be a heavy focus on concrete.
So it may be a little
tough to imagine.
But basically, I'm
combining a concrete pump,
which is the
material which would
get pushed through
to the nozzles,
a robotic arm, which
has sensors on it,
is very precise, and
autonomous mobile base unit.
And the three of them
combined will kind of
drive around construction
sites and extrude the concrete
and build walls with
almost no labor.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
So the idea is it would set
the foundation without having
to do the forming?
TONY CAPASSO: Well,
the foundation
is pretty much flat work.
So that would be
poured conventionally,
just using regular man hours.
So this would be kind
of a hybrid version.
But the vertical
walls could actually
be printed with no labor at all.
So it would be a
hybrid of a masonry
wall and a concrete wall, but
there's no form work required.
So that's where the labor
saving comes into play.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
So how far along are you guys?
TONY CAPASSO: I've built
some little prototypes, kind
of desktop versions of it, with
a Mecanum kind of vectoring
robot and an arm on top of it.
And have done little samples to
kind of do a proof of concept.
And now I'm raising a
funding round, basically,
to do everything at full scale.
KORY JEFFREY:
That's really cool.
So prior to this,
you were actually
in the project management
of construction.
Talk to me a little bit
about the transition from one
to tech entrepreneurship.
TONY CAPASSO: Sure.
So again, my family
immigrated from Italy.
And they were all
amazing contractors.
My father started his
own business here.
And we're one of the largest
subcontractors in Connecticut
right now.
We do a lot of work
for Yale University
and a lot of public schools.
So my background
isn't technology.
It's actually an end user,
and seeing the problems
with construction, which
is, I think, great for me,
because I have an
expertise in a domain.
And I'll really be able to get
that product market fit instead
of building something that
let's say a user wouldn't want.
KORY JEFFREY: Yeah.
Makes a lot of sense.
Not a technology in search
of a solution, right?
That's cool.
And so you've had some
highlights as well.
I believe you won a TV show.
Can you talk a little
bit about that?
TONY CAPASSO: Yeah, sure.
So when I started
with this idea,
I got introduced to Tim
Draper, who is a venture
capitalist, Draper Associates.
And he also started a school
called Draper University.
And it takes early
stage startups
and kind of coaches them through
the entrepreneurship process.
At the same time,
it was a TV show.
It was called "Startup U."
And it was on ABC Family.
And I got cast for the show.
So after the 10 episodes,
we pitch our businesses.
So it's kind of like a
hybrid of "The Real World"
mixed with "Shark Tank."
And it was a really
cool experience.
So at the end of it,
we pitch to a room
full of venture capitalists.
And they all vote on
the idea that they
think is the most
forward thinking,
and I guess the right team.
And I ended up winning some
funding for my company.
KORY JEFFREY: That's awesome.
Congratulations.
So you just came
off the main stage,
talking to thousands of people
here, all interested in tech
entrepreneurship in some way.
What was your message?
What were you talking about?
TONY CAPASSO: I
think my message was
to make startups great again.
So I actually had
some hats made up
that say, "Make
Startups Great Again,"
And it was kind of a
play with Donald Trump,
"Make America Great Again."
But I think that's
the important thing.
You see a lot of startups
that just do one thing that's
a little bit better.
And they're not reaching
far enough out there
and really pushing the envelope.
So I think what I'm working
on was pretty flattering.
Tim said to me that it might
have been one of the largest
markets he's ever invested in.
And if I am able
to succeed, this
is just such a
massive disruption
to literally the world's
oldest industry, right?
So I think, shoot
for the stars, right?
KORY JEFFREY: Real
disruption rather than
incremental difference.
TONY CAPASSO: Exactly.
KORY JEFFREY: Cool.
So you know, you're going to see
a lot of different technologies
here.
Obviously, there's thousands of
people here, a lot of demoing.
Is there anything
besides 3D printing
that really gets you excited
in the technology space today?
TONY CAPASSO: I think virtual
reality is pretty interesting.
I think it has some
really cool applications.
I've used it a couple times.
You put it on and you really
almost forget where you are
or what you're doing.
And I also see that as
being integrated well
with the construction industry.
So being able to walk
into a building that's
half of the way done and be able
to see the finishes on the wall
or something like
that really helps you.
It's going to streamline
the whole process.
KORY JEFFREY: Do you have a
favorite Google technology?
TONY CAPASSO: Gmail.
KORY JEFFREY: Gmail?
TONY CAPASSO: Gmail
is my favorite by far.
KORY JEFFREY: You
use it all the time?
TONY CAPASSO: Yeah.
KORY JEFFREY: Me too, actually.
TONY CAPASSO: That's by far.
KORY JEFFREY: That's good.
That's awesome.
Well, thank you very
much for joining me.
TONY CAPASSO: Yeah, thank you.
KORY JEFFREY: And thank
you guys for joining me
on site at Founder World.
My name is Kory.
[MUSIC PLAYING]